[Music]
when I first moved to Stanford from
Harvard I got my first a close-up view
of Silicon Valley ad this was about a
year and a half ago and what most struck
me was the hubris the arrogance that I
encountered there the general view of a
reasonably high up computer scientist is
that history began around about the
Google IPO or maybe the founding of
Facebook and everything before that is
the Stone Age and is of no possible
interest to the world that has been
transformed by Silicon Valley and I had
a hard time persuading people that they
didn't invent social networks the social
networks have always existed and all
that they did was to create large indeed
vast online social networks bigger and
faster really than anything that's
existed before but not I think
fundamentally different in the way that
they work and a good illustration of
this is that extraordinary mm their era
of networks that I think began right
back in the early 1500s almost exactly
500 years ago with the Reformation that
network driven revolution wouldn't have
happened without the printing press and
it's the beginning of a succession of
waves of networked revolution for
example the Scientific Revolution of the
17th century is essentially the result
of there being a distributed network of
scholars all over Europe and Beyond are
innovating in the realm of natural
science the Enlightenment is a
comparable network driven revolution in
political thought and one part of that
18th century network which is
tremendously important its Freemasonry
now most people have heard of
Freemasonry probably know where there's
a Masonic Lodge in their town but in my
experience not many people know that
much
the history of Freemasonry that's partly
because the Masons themselves have a
kind of fake history that dates
Freemasonry back to the very ancient
times in truth it's something that got
going in the British Isles in the 18th
century and and was a kind of Facebook
like phenomenon of male sociability in
18th century Europe and indeed it
crossed the Atlantic and became a big
part of American life in the colonial
era Masonic lodges were essentially
clubs they were clubs that stood apart
from the existing structures of social
order the early modern division of
society into ranks or estates were set
aside religious divisions were set aside
and in Masonic lodges at rather
ritualistic dinners men of all classes
and men of different denominations could
meet and mingle and exchange ideas and
often these ideas were drawn from the
the prevailing ideas of the 18th century
so it's quite hard to understand the
Enlightenment and indeed the American
and French Revolutions without
recognizing that a structure within
which ideas spread was the structure of
Masonic lodges if you look at the people
who sign the Declaration of Independence
look at some of the key players in the
American Revolution it's surprising how
many were freemasons including George
Washington himself I told the story in
the square and the Tower of Paul Revere
he of the famous ride and an another
Bostonian revolutionary a Joseph Warren
and show that one reason they were able
to exert a very important leadership
role when the Revolution began was that
they were so well-connected in Boston
society through their membership of
of a Masonic Lodge as well as other more
political clubs so I think that
illustrates one important point and that
is that you don't need the Internet to
have an international network that can
be really quite powerful when it is
mobilized the other point that's worth
adding is that as so often in the
history of social networks conspiracy
theories have sprung up around the
Freemasons and if you go online and
google Freemasonry you'll get a kind of
interesting mix of content produced by
Mason's and content produced by people
who suspect about Freemasons of being
some kind of sinister conspiracy and
this is one of the things that makes
writing the history of social networks
quite difficult there's this penumbra of
mystery that the theorists who write
about conspiracies make it quite hard
for us serious scholars to write about
those subjects you have to strip away a
lot of of myth making in order to get at
the reality
[Music]